elle est l'amour secret de Vladimir
Poutine depuis 15 ans voici l'histoire
d'allina Kabaeva une ex championne
olympique de GRS qui partagerait en
secret la vie du président de la Russie
en Russie à lina est une icône cette
gymnaste qui a révolutionné la GRS a
raflé toutes les médailles de l'or
olympique au titre mondiaux européen et
nationaux au début des années 2000 elle
multiplie les émissions de télévision et
les couvertures de magazines à l'époque
Kabaeva assume sa carrière et sa
renommée mais tout change en 2008 au
moment de son élection en tant que
député au Parlement russe la révélation
de sa supposée relation avec Vladimir
Poutine marque un tournant et quand elle
abandonne son siège en 2014 Alina
bascule dans un monde secret c'est à
peine si elle continue à fréquenter ses
amis Vladimir Poutine qui n'a jamais
étalé sa vie privée démant toutes les
rumeurs qui ont commencé en 2008 sont
passés d'Aix à Jean du KGB fait qu'il a
toujours compartimenté sa vie on ne
connaît donc que leur rencontre
officielle dans un cadre sportif ou
politique mais Alina et sa famille
profitent de nombreux appartements
voyage et invitations et à Lina vit dans
une maison construite pour elle au sein
de la résidence présidentielle de Valdaï
d'autres faits mettent la puce à
l'oreille en 2012 la gymnaste reçoit
Moscou des gymnastes à la retraite à les
interroge sur leur maternité et confie
être devenu maman mais le jour où elle
apparaît avec un petit garçon dans les
bras cabaeva panique et essaie
d'étouffer la rumeur son deuxième enfant
serait né quatre ans plus tard dans une
maternité conseillable Vladimir Poutine
par Silvio perlusconi aujourd'hui Alina
ne peut plus voyager à cause des
sanctions prises contre les oligarques
russes et leurs proches depuis la guerre
en Ukraine si ses proches assurent
qu'elle reste cette jeune femme ouverte
et charmante depuis 2014 plus personne
ne la voit